yes hello this time a short video in
german which might irritate one or the other
but it
actually only makes sense in german
i just want to give a short
hint and that there is a new
podcast in german about chess
and i have it here now  the youtube
version could be called up
you can watch it on youtube yes of course
but in the video there is only one
picture to see and there is still
the sound of this podcast chess whisper
it is called it is also there i think
on the other typical
platforms i think the  means that apple podcast for
example or suspect also spotify
and something like that i'm not an expert but
you will
find there is more than one platform where it
can be heard and it applies to all
15 episodes and i was a guest in
this podcast everyone  shortly afterwards that
is of course not listening for a little more than
an hour I was there at the beginning of the year
at the beginning of January but  only
now really managed to
do it
in July many interesting topics and guests
clearly it is in German that's why we
also have German guests for example other
guests who were there recently
yes jonathan karlstedt who we have already
commented on at the German youth championships
I think he's a trainer at werder bremen
at the moment or here georgios solides
the name of the big creek design channel he
may also know from various
other journalistic activities wrote a
book he also knows
guest yes so the whole thing is
still fairly new and if there's a
bit over  want to hear chess because it's
a good format for example when you
're on the go and because you
don't want to hear a bit of chess when you're on the train ride
or i sometimes have a
podcast in the car so that's
actually a nice addition if
you just can't do without  scarf endures
very nice made i think about it
all the time if i say
is supposed to be the name of the maker yes i don't think
the name is anywhere in there will
certainly say again himself
so that's made by a
shaft enthusiast who has a rating of about
17 to 1800 so just so
that's not so professional talks to
professional  but yes, there are also many
interesting questions that an
amateur might have now compared to a chess
professional or somehow otherwise involved with
chess
yes, well, I hope he finds
something nice to listen to and if
she is on youtube because of watching too,
thank you very much for listening